Profª. Tamar Gendler: OK.
Então, o que eu quero fazer na
1ª parte desta aula
é terminar a nossa
discussão sobre liberdade,
começando por dizer mais
algumas coisas esclarecedoras
sobre as páginas de Nozick que lemos,
e depois explicar o que eu acredito
ser uma forma importante
de Nozick e Rawls encararem
um dos problemas
que cada um deles tem enfrentado:
o problema da sorte para
determinar a experiência humana.
E quando terminarmos isso,
vamos passar para as 2 leituras
empíricas que fizemos para hoje.
Portanto, vocês se lembram que
nas páginas de Nozick,
a sua 1ª preocupação
é apresentar um quadro geral de
reflexão sobre a filosofia política
num contexto que prioriza a
liberdade e os direitos.
E, em particular, na
leitura do Capítulo 7,
a sua preocupação é com a
articulação de um ponto de vista
sobre a legitimidade do
direito da propriedade,
que tem como principal
justificativa 3 partes.
A 1ª, vocês se lembram,
é a noção de justiça na
aquisição de Nozick.
E nós comentamos sobre as
condições em que Nozick pensa
que é legítimo que alguém venha a
adquirir uma propriedade.
E a ideia básica é que é
legítimo se apropriar de algo
de estoque comum sem dono,
desde que, fazendo isso,
não se viole o que Nozick chama
de condição lockeana.
Ou seja, desde que se deixe o
"suficiente e tão bom para os outros".
E nós consideramos 2 objeções
a esse ponto de vista.
Uma delas, a ideia de que ocorre uma
espécie de descompressão
que faz com que inclusive a 1ª
aquisição seja ilegítima,
caso a propriedade se esgote.
A 2ª está baseada no
problema dos comuns,
de que chegará um momento
em que alguém parecerá
estar em desvantagem
por causa da apropriação de outrem,
e comentamos sobre as
respostas de Nozick.
E a minha esperança é que nas
seções desta semana
vocês tenham a chance de pensar
se elas são legítimas.
Depois, vimos a opinião de Nozick
sobre justiça na transferência,
defendendo que qualquer
transferência em que 2 pessoas
estejam dispostas a se
envolver é legítima.
É uma restrição ilegítima à
liberdade das pessoas,
na visão de Nozick,
limitar o que você está autorizado a
fazer com a sua propriedade.
Mas Nozick reconhece
– e nós não chegamos a este
ponto na última aula –
que, além disso, há uma necessidade
para um 3º tipo de noção.
E é a ideia de que muitas vezes
a propriedade é adquirida
ilegitimamente,
seja na origem ou como efeito de uma
transferência ilegítima.
E que, no que diz respeito a
isso, é necessário,
na opinião dele, algum tipo
de retificação.
E isso dá origem a uma
passagem bastante marcante
no final do capítulo lido
para a semana passada.
Nozick escreve que, na verdade,
existem incidências prévias de
injustiça na aquisição da propriedade.
Esta nação, por exemplo, foi
fundada na escravidão negra.
E Nozick observa que o grupo dos
menos favorecidos da sociedade
agora têm as maiores probabilidades
de serem os descendentes de vítimas
de injustiça mais grave.
Como consequência, ele explica,
talvez seja o caso de utilizar o
seguinte princípio básico...
Talvez devêssemos fazer o
que sugere Rawls
e organizar a sociedade para
beneficiar os menos favorecidos.
Segundo Nozick, as injustiças do
passado podem ser enormes,
obrigando, a curto prazo, um
Estado mais amplo
do que aquele que Nozick tem vindo a
defender, a fim de retificá-las.
A página 231 de Anarquia,
Estado e Utopia diz
que uma boa regra talvez seja
organizar a sociedade
para beneficiar os menos favorecidos.
Afinal de contas, Nozick e
Rawls estão de acordo?
Bom, percebam o que Nozick
argumentou antes...
Mesmo nos engajando nesse ato
temporário de reorganização,
a liberdade perturba os padrões.
Dê a todos o mesmo cofrinho, dê a
eles a liberdade para fazer
o que quiserem com o dinheiro
deles e, inevitavelmente,
será o caso de que alguns
estarão melhores que outros.
Além disso, como vimos no final
da nossa última aula,
essas distribuições de riqueza podem
acabar tendo consequências,
em que decidir se elas violam pelo menos
o espírito da cláusula
lockeana se torna uma pergunta
bastante difícil de responder.
No final da última aula,
vimos que pode existir uma sociedade
em que há uma distribuição
igualitária da riqueza
entre os indivíduos
e uma interação social entre eles no que
diz respeito às instituições
que preparam as pessoas para serem
cidadãos democráticos.
Porém, como demonstrado
no último slide,
se é inevitável que uma estrutura
deste tipo acabe resultando
numa distribuição desigual de riqueza
e essa desigualdade traz
consigo a liberdade
de optar pela saída de certas
instituições públicas,
criando as privadas a partir das quais
se pode afastar os recursos
que uma vez pertenceram às públicas,
então particularmente nos casos
da educação e da saúde
– que podemos pensar
como precondições
para a participação na democracia –,
é complicado afirmar que esses tipos de
distribuições são justificáveis.
Portanto, Nozick nos apresenta uma ideia
de que tipo de ações são permitidas.
Por um momento, é como se
Nozick concordasse com Rawls
que um certo tipo de
redistribuição é permitido.
Mas, em último caso, não
existe esse estímulo,
pelo menos num sentido óbvio, para
evitar situações como a citada.
Agora, é uma questão aberta
saber se a pessoa toma isso
como uma prioridade para evitar
situações como a citada.
Mas é um fato marcante em Uma Teoria
da Justiça e em Anarquia,
Estado e Utopia que os seus índices
não fazem nenhuma referência
à educação, nenhum
referência à infância,
mas apenas uma consciência
limitada do tema,
o que será central na nossa
discussão de hoje.
Ou seja, as formas das estruturas
sociais que nos rodeiam
acabam afetando o tipo de
preferências que temos,
além do tipo de escolhas que fazemos.
Vocês se lembram que a
questão principal,
a que fundamenta o debate sobre
o que torna legítimo
uma estrutura particular na sociedade,
é aquela articulada por Rawls
no início de Uma Teoria...,
apresentada para vocês como o
2º tópico do ensaio
para o conjunto final de ensaios.
Rawls aponta que uma sociedade é
"um empreendimento
cooperativo de vantagem
mútua
tipicamente marcada por um conflito,
bem como por uma identidade de
interesses", e afirma,
seguindo Hobbes na tradição
do contrato social,
que há uma identidade de
interesses na cooperação social
que faz da vida melhor
do que se vivêssemos sem cooperação.
Há também um conflito de interesses,
uma vez que as pessoas não
são indiferentes
à forma como esses bens
são distribuídos.
Agora, em algum nível, podemos conceber
um aspecto do debate em
questão em que Rawls diz:
se as coisas saem moldadas
de uma forma que, por trás do
véu da ignorância,
você não as queria,
intervenha e redistribua.
Enquanto Nozick afirma: se as
coisas saem como o resultado
de ações livres entre
indivíduos livres,
então, independentemente de como
seja esse padrão, aceite-o.
É possível ver essa diferença
de perspectiva entre eles
como uma diferença de perspectiva sobre
como estamos moralmente
obrigados a lidar com o fato,
na medida em que ocorram
coisas que nos afetam,
determinando o que está e o que
não está sob nosso controle,
na medida em que isso é importante
para as nossas próprias
reações internas aos eventos,
como assinalou Epicteto.
Na medida em que isso é importante
para a nossa tendência em responder
conforme os nossos compromissos,
como Aristóteles e Doris no debate de
Doris com Aristóteles questionaram.
E na medida em que isso abrange a nossa
atribuição de louvor e culpa
em casos de boa ou má
conduta não-intencional,
nas discussões de sorte moral e
punição e Kant versus Mill
sobre se há mérito moral em
salvar uma criança.
Em todos esses casos, a
questão fundamental é esta:
que tipo de postura é a postura
adequada para os seres humanos
tomarem, uma vez que, como diz Epicteto:
"algumas coisas dependem de
nós e outras não"?
Se analisarmos Uma Teoria da
Justiça de Rawls,
lemos as seguintes passagens:
"Os dois princípios mencionados"...
o 1º princípio diz que os
direitos são intocáveis,
a grosso modo, todo
indivíduo tem direito
a certas liberdades básicas e que
nenhuma utilidade pode substitui-las.
E o 2º princípio diz que as
desigualdades devem ser distribuídas
como resultado de ofícios
que são abertos
de forma equitativa a todos e de tal
modo que as desigualdades
sejam para beneficiar os
menos favorecidos.
Rawls diz: "Os dois princípios, aqui
mencionados, parecem ser um
'acordo equitativo' nos quais se
baseiam os melhores bem dotados,
ou os mais avantajados socialmente,
nenhum dos quais
podendo esperar a cooperação
voluntária dos outros,
enquanto um esquema viável for
condição necessária
para o bem-estar de todos.
Desde que tenhamos decidido
procurar um conceito de justiça
que anule as vantagens
naturais fortuitas
e as contingências das
circunstâncias sociais adversas
na procura por vantagens
políticas e econômicas,
somos conduzidos a estes princípios.
Estes últimos expressariam o resultado
de se deixar de lado os
aspectos do mundo social,
que seriam arbitrários
do ponto de vista moral".
Vantagens naturais fortuitas.
Contingências das
circunstâncias sociais.
Aspectos do mundo social, que
seriam arbitrários
do ponto de vista moral.
Rawls está envolvido no antigo
projeto de pensar sobre
como lidar com a sorte moral.
E porque a distribuição
de bens e vantagens
– tanto no âmbito do "eu"
e entre "eus" –
em muitos aspectos não depende de nós,
Rawls conclui que os princípios
articulados em Uma Teoria...
são o que a justiça exige.
Nozick, por outro lado, também
se preocupa com a sorte.
Vejamos as passagens do
final do Capítulo 7.
Aqui, Nozick argumenta – com
base num texto de Rawls –
que Rawls tem razão ao rejeitar um
sistema de liberdade natural.
Isso permite que parcelas distributivas
sejam injustamente influenciadas
por fatores tão arbitrários do
ponto de vista moral.
Nozick diz que Rawls está tentando lidar
com o problema da sorte moral.
Esses fatores, segundo
ele, citando Rawls,
são "distribuições anteriores de
talentos e habilidades naturais
na medida em que foram
desenvolvidos ao longo do tempo
por circunstâncias sociais e por
contingências aleatórias,
como acaso e boa sorte".
Nozick observa que Rawls está
preocupado com coisas
que não dependem de nós.
Mas não há, para Nozick, nenhuma
menção de como as pessoas
resolveram desenvolver os
seus talentos naturais.
E é ao reconhecer a contraparte
de que algumas coisas
não dependem de nós
– ou seja, que algumas coisas
dependem de nós –
que encontramos a noção de
deserto legítimo
à luz deste debate eterno.
Esta linha de raciocínio, afirma
Nozick na crítica a Rawls,
pode ter sucesso ao bloquear a
introdução de escolhas autônomas
e ações de uma pessoa e
os resultados delas
apenas ao atribuir tudo
notável sobre a pessoa
a certos tipos de fatores externos.
Mas se pensarmos nas pessoas
tal como definidas pelas suas
circunstâncias de forma que sugeriria
uma extensão lógica desta
visão, Nozick diz:
"denegrir a autonomia e a
responsabilidade fundamental
de uma pessoa pelos seus atos é
uma orientação arriscada
para uma teoria que, à parte isso,
deseja reforçar a dignidade
e o respeito próprio de
seres autônomos".
Estamos de volta à nossa
pergunta essencial.
Considerando que somos seres
influenciados pelo mundo
à nossa volta de uma forma
muito difícil de entender,
até que ponto merecemos o crédito
por aquilo que percebemos ter
feito voluntariamente?
E até que ponto, pensando sob
a perspectiva de nós
como protagonistas da
estrutura do mundo, se trata
de um equívoco total os nossos
caráteres e circunstâncias estarem
tão intimamente ligados com as coisas
que fogem ao nosso controle?
Portanto, eu quero lembrá-los que o
que começou como um debate
sobre a legitimidade da tributação
termina como um dos nossos
debates filosóficos centrais.
Uma e outra vez somos
confrontados com a nossa
condição
de seres no mundo, afetando
e sendo afetados.
Eu quero abordar este tema nos
outros 30 minutos de aula,
em 2 artigos empíricos particulares
no contexto da nossa discussão
sobre as estruturas sociais.
Lembrem-se que iniciamos esta
unidade de filosofia política
com O Leviatã de Hobbes
e esbarramos no seu argumento de que,
por causa de certos fatos
sobre a natureza humana
– basicamente o nosso desejo de
controlar os bens à nossa volta
e a limitação do número de
bens existentes –,
estaremos num estado de
natureza de uma guerra
de todos contra todos.
E, então, nós analisamos uma
representação matemática disso
na forma do Dilema do Prisioneiro
e, em seguida, consideramos 2
respostas particulares
na tradição filosófica
anglo-americana ocidental do século
– ou seja, Rawls e Nozick –
para pensar como parece uma
sociedade legítima
no contexto dos fatos sobre
a natureza humana.
O que eu quero fazer na parte da aula
dedicada às estruturas sociais
é apresentar como as
estruturas à nossa volta
acabam determinando as nossas atitudes,
pelo menos tanto quanto as nossas
atitudes acabam determinando
as estruturas sociais à nossa volta.
Este é um tema que já
vimos em Aristóteles.
Portanto, nas páginas finais
de Ética a Nicômaco,
que lemos há cerca de 1
mês, Aristóteles,
num capítulo intitulado Transição da
Moralidade a Filosofia Política,
observa que: "se os argumentos
bastassem em si mesmos para
tornar os homens bons, eles teriam
feito jus a grandes recompensas
e as recompensas não faltariam".
Mas "não é fácil
alterar pelo argumento"
o que tem sido absorvido como
consequência dos hábitos.
Então, pergunta Aristóteles,
como poderíamos mudar as
pessoas se o argumento
não é suficiente para tornar
as pessoas decentes?
Bem, ele aponta que é difícil para
alguém ser treinado corretamente
desde a sua juventude, se ele não está
educado sob as leis corretas.
"Levar uma vida temperante
não seduz os jovens."
É por isso que uma das coisas
sobre esta imagem antiga de
governança, uma das coisas
que a lei deve prescrever é a
educação e as práticas.
Porque, se eles são
levados a se comportarem
de determinadas maneiras isso não
será doloroso pra eles.
Aristóteles está falando de
uma função da lei
que vai nos ocupar tanto hoje quanto na
quinta – a função da lei
na formação do caráter dos
cidadãos que a governam.
Mas esse tema não é encontrado
apenas em Aristóteles.
John Stuart Mill, autor da
famosa obra On Liberty
e do Utilitarismo, este
último lido nesta aula,
traça o mesmo ponto de Aristóteles.
Ao comentar sobre a forma de
estruturar a sociedade de forma
adequada, maximizando a
quantidade de utilidade produzida
por ela, ele escreve: "a utilidade
prescreve, em primeiro lugar,
que as leis e estruturas sociais
coloquem tanto quanto possível
a felicidade ou (para falar
em termos práticos)
o interesse de qualquer indivíduo
em harmonia com o todo".
Uma sociedade bem estruturada, no
ponto de vista de Mill,
gerencia a relação entre o
indivíduo e a comunidade.
E a utilidade prescreve, de acordo com
isso, que "que a educação
e a opinião, que têm um poder tão
grande sobre o caráter humano,
usem esse poder para estabelecer
na mente do indivíduo
uma associação indissolúvel entre
a sua própria felicidade
e o bem comum".
Educação e opinião, ambas
têm um poder enorme
sobre o caráter humano.
Este é o tema da aula de hoje.
E em uns 4 slides vamos usar os clickers
porque já estamos no fim do semestre
e eu quero vocês acordados.
Podem ir pegando os clickers; eu
vou comentar umas coisas
e, depois, vamos à votação.
Tudo bem.
Assim, a 1º texto lido para
hoje é um extenso artigo
da revista Behavioral and
Brain Sciences,
em que os autores investigam um valor
de pesquisa antropológica
e psicológica, numa tentativa de
respaldar empiricamente
a alegação de Mill – que a
educação e a opinião,
as estruturas culturais,
têm um grande poder sobre
o caráter humano.
Os autores argumentam neste
papel que os cidadãos,
a quem eles chamam de "OEIRD"
(isto é: Ocidental, Educado,
Industrializados, Ricos,
Democrático)...
as pessoas que foram trazidas à
consciência numa sociedade
que possui essas 5 características.
Eles argumentam que esses
indivíduos são estranhos, ou seja,
diferem em aspectos cruciais na
atitude deles para com o mundo
se os comparamos com indivíduos
que vêm de sociedades
não-industrializadas de pequena
escala,
na comparação com pessoas que vêm
de sociedades industriais
não-ocidentais, com pessoas que vêm
de outras sociedades
industrializadas ocidentais
e mesmo com outros cidadãos
do seu próprio país
que não têm formação universitária.
Em especial, alegam os autores,
os domínios que vemos a
esquisitice do "OEIRD"
(a pessoa atípica do Ocidente,
educado, industrializado,
rico e democrático)
incluem a percepção,
categorização, memória,
atenção,
cognição espacial, conceitos
autônomos, juízos de equidade,
tendências para a cooperação,
tendências para a conformidade,
juízos morais e assim por diante.
Num grande número de domínios, vocês
– incluindo aqueles de vocês que não
são de culturas ocidentais –
diferem da grande maioria
dos 6, 7 bilhões de outras
pessoas na Terra.
E, com certeza, da grande maioria
das pessoas que viveram na
Terra ao longo do tempo.
Como um resultado das experiências
culturais que vocês tiveram,
a percepção, a apreensão
e os padrões de atenção
foram afetados.
Portanto, os autores escreveram o artigo
com um objetivo específico em mente.
Eles escreveram isso num
esforço de argumentar
que as pesquisas psicológicas do
tipo que enche as revistas,
incluindo a que eles publicaram
este texto, deveriam
estar fundamentadas em amostras
populacionais mais amplas.
Eles utilizam esse argumento
porque eles estão preocupados
com a possibilidade de revelar
diferenças entre os seres humanos,
como as pessoas criadas num
tipo de circunstância
diferem das pessoas criadas em outro...
E também porque eles estão
profundamente preocupados
em identificar como existem
os pontos em comum.
E vocês vão notar, à medida
que lemos o artigo,
que cada uma das 4 seções
principais começa
com uma série de contrastes
entre as pessoas "OEIRD"
e qualquer que seja o outro grupo,
mas ele termina com um
conjunto de pontos em comum
entre os 2 grupos, o que sugere,
pelo menos à primeira vista,
que existem semelhanças profundas,
provavelmente o resultado de
pressões evolutivas.
Mas este não é um curso de
psicologia evolutiva.
Este também não é um curso
de metodologia da psicologia.
Então por que lemos este
artigo? Por 4 motivos.
O 1º é que se trata de um
curso, como vocês sabem,
chamado de Filosofia e a
Ciência da Natureza Humana.
E este artigo,
talvez mais densamente que
qualquer outro artigo,
contém inúmeros fatos
muito interessantes
sobre as maneiras que as
pessoas podem ser.
Portanto, a 1ª razão para se ler o
artigo é aprender alguns fatos
sobre a diversidade e a
semelhança humana.
Além disso, como vocês sabes,
este é um curso "e"...
Este é um curso, como eu
disse desde a 1ª aula,
que tenta reunir diferentes
perspectivas sobre as questões.
E uma das coisas que eu acho que
este artigo faz muito bem,
particularmente em conjunto com o
2º artigo lido para hoje,
é dar uma série de ferramentas
para a reflexão sobre
questões centrais.
Uma das coisas que o artigo
nos desafia a fazer
ao observar um comportamento e
fazer uma generalização
sobre a sua base é perguntar
o quão "generalizável"
realmente é esse comportamento?
Mas este também é um curso, e
este é o 3º motivo
para se ler o artigo, que
apresenta, como se sabe,
um cara morto na terça e
Ciência Cognitiva na quinta...
e hoje é quinta.
Assim, a 3ª coisa que o artigo faz
é informá-los sobre uma
crítica recente,
realizada no ano passado
(o artigo foi publicado em 2010)...
conscientizá-los sobre
uma crítica ligada
a uma parte da base
investigativa do curso.
Uma das coisas que estamos
fazendo durante o semestre,
que todos vocês fizeram no
exercício dirigido 5,
foi analisar alguns artigos
cujas amostragens limitadas estão
sendo desafiadas neste artigo.
Finalmente, estamos lendo esta obra
no contexto da nossa seção
de filosofia política
numa aula chamada estruturas sociais,
pois parece fundamental para mim,
quando alguém quer se envolver a
sério em filosofia política,
apresentar a complexa série
de considerações
que devem ser consideradas ao
refletir sobre como as sociedades
devem ser estruturadas.
Então, o que eu quero fazer na
próxima parte da aula é percorrer
3 exemplos dos tipos de casos que o
artigo "OEIRD" se preocupa.
São 3 casos em que é
feita uma alegação
que essa experiência afetou a
sua percepção de mundo.
E eu começo com a mais dramática.
Talvez não seja a melhor estabelecida.
Nós vamos falar sobre isso...
Mas é a alegação mais dramática.
Eu gostaria que vocês
pegassem os clickers
e dessem uma olhada nestas coisas aqui.
E me digam se, entre os 2 segmentos,
o superior parece ser
menor que o inferior
ou pode ser que eles tenham o
mesmo comprimento?
Estamos falando apenas dos
segmentos de linha aqui.
Ou seja, que o inferior é
menor que o superior.
E nós vamos ter 10, 9, 8,
7, 6, 4, 3, 2, 1...
para ver como saem os números.
Assim, 41% de vocês acham
que a linha de cima é
menor que a de baixo.
Para 46% de vocês, elas
são do mesmo tamanho.
Ao passo que 14% disseram
que a linha inferior aparece
menor que a superior.
14% de vocês... vamos lá
ver... estão corretos.
A parte inferior é mais
curta que a superior.
Vocês querem ver novamente?
Tudo bem.
Então o que está acontecendo aqui?
Eu tenho a mesma animação
no slide seguinte,
porque eu não tinha a certeza
se vocês se animariam
com um slide com gráficos.
Mas acontece que vocês se animaram.
OK, então, de novo....
Estes são idênticos.
Estes são duplicatas.
Eu os criei e medi
com um programa de
medição do PowerPoint.
Então, este tem, na verdade, 7,87cm
e este tem 7,62cm de comprimento.
O de baixo é menor que o de cima.
Agora, tem sido argumentado que
a tendência de vocês
perceberem esta linha, quando
incorporada dentro desta figura,
como maior que este segmento
quando incorporado na figura
é o resultado de vocês terem crescido
num ambiente com esquinas carpintejadas.
A afirmação
está baseada em pesquisas
feitas na década de 1960
num grande número de
comunidades não-urbanizadas
e pequena escala, que a discrepância
entre os tamanhos da linha,
os comprimentos dos segmentos,
é extremamente diferente em
sociedades de pequena escala,
onde não há, de acordo com a pesquisa,
nenhuma tendência a se deixar
levar por essas extensões.
Para a sociedade ocidental – isto é,
Evanston, Illinois e África do Sul
– há uma tendência a achar essa
ilusão massivamente atraente.
Agora, é complicado determinar se
estes dados têm peso ou não,
porque a pesquisa foi feita
há quase 50 anos,
quando as ferramentas para
realizar essas perguntas
possuíam padrões diferentes do
que as pessoas possuem hoje,
no entanto, é plausível pensar
que isso possa ser verdade.
A experiência determina todos
os tipos de coisas.
E não é inimaginável que entre as
coisas que poderiam determinar
está o tipo de
características
perceptivas
que você escolhe ao se
deparar com uma situação.
É, no mínimo, inegável que
existam diferenças fundamentais
e interessantes entre a
tendência daqueles criados
nas culturas orientais e daqueles
criados nas culturas ocidentais
para valer-se de 2 tipos de processos
fundamentais de raciocínio
que estão disponíveis
para cada um de nós.
Então vocês sabem, tanto
pelas leituras de hoje
quanto pelas leituras sobre o
modelo de duplo processamento
no início do semestre, que os
seres humanos são capazes
do que é chamado de
processamento holístico.
Isso é a orientação para um
objeto inserido num contexto,
prestando atenção às
relações entre o objeto
e o campo focal que o rodeia e
tendo uma tendência,
como consequência, de fazer
previsões e oferecer explicações
sobre a base destas
propriedades relacionais.
Esse é um tipo de pensamento.
E todos nós o temos disponível.
Mas, além disso, existe um
2º tipo de pensamento
que todo ser humano adulto tem acesso:
o processamento analítico, através
do qual é possível orientar
em direção a um objeto
de forma isolada,
prestando atenção principalmente
nos atributos do objeto,
não nas características do
ambiente ao redor,
e exibindo uma tendência para prever
e explicar os acontecimentos
com base em tais atributos.
Vocês se lembram de quando
estávamos lendo a crítica de Doris
a Aristóteles e a sugestão foi
que não são as
características do
indivíduo,
não são os atributos do objeto,
que determinam como alguém
vai agir numa situação
potencialmente moral.
Mas, em vez disso,
são as características da sua
relação com o contexto.
Quer tenha achado uma moeda de US$
0,10 na cabine telefônica,
quer esteja numa corrida.
A afirmação feita por Doris na
crítica a Aristóteles,
uma versão chamada de erro
fundamental de atribuição,
é que há casos em que o
processamento analítico nos enviesa
e o processamento holístico faz um
melhor trabalho de explicação.
Também há casos em que
concentrar a nossa atenção
profundamente no próprio objeto,
sem atender as características
irrelevantes do ambiente,
nos deixa em melhor situação.
É impressionante que pareça existir
diferenças confiáveis ??
e estatisticamente
significativas ao longo do
tempo
em membros de culturas
ocidentais e não-ocidentais
no que diz respeito a qual destas
atitudes eles tomam como padrão.
Assim, numa série de artigos escritos
ao longo da última década,
Richard Nisbett e vários
colaboradores apresentaram
as seguintes sugestões aos indivíduos.
Eles mostraram uma série de peixes
contra um fundo específico.
E, depois, mostraram uma
série de novos peixes,
com os mesmos fundos ou diferentes.
Ou uma série de ursos polares ou
alces contra um fundo específico
e, depois, objetos novos ou vistos antes
contra um fundo semelhante ou diferente.
Então, qual foi a vantagem
demonstrada pelos indivíduos
ao ver um objeto que eles já tinham
visto num contexto familiar?
Para os indivíduos japoneses
testados por Nisbett,
um objeto visto contra o
seu fundo original
produz uma alta taxa de precisão.
Se você mostrá-lo sem um
fundo, há menos precisão.
E se você mostrá-lo
contra um fundo novo,
há um decréscimo
marcante no desempenho.
E outra vez com os lobos...
Se você mostrar isso contra o fundo
original... alta precisão.
Se mostrar isso contra um fundo novo...
um decréscimo significativo.
Esses são os padrões de limpeza.
O que acontece com os
indivíduos ocidentais?
Um padrão completamente diferente.
O fundo original não ajuda na
re-identificação.
Não ter fundo ajuda muito.
A distração da informação
adicional foi removida.
E um fundo novo não os deixa
muito pior que o original.
Idem com os lobos.
O fundo original produz alguma,
mas não muita, vantagem.
Eu vou pular o próximo
exemplo, o que sugere...
e vocês poderão ver isto no
slide que eu vou publicar...
que, novamente, há contextos
em que os ocidentais
parecem ser melhores em
tarefas absolutas
e os não-ocidentais em
tarefas relativas.
Agora que tipo de negócio temos ao
fazer essas generalizações
sobre as culturas?
Fazer isso não é um ultraje?
A alegação é que a cultura
não determina tudo
sobre uma pessoa.
A alegação surpreendente é que
crescer em circunstâncias em
que a sua atenção é,
como uma questão de rumo,
dirigida de formas específicas,
irá conduzi-lo exatamente do jeito
que Aristóteles sugeriu,
a encontrar essas formas de respostas
para ser natural e habitual.
Então, nos 5 minutos finais da aula eu
queroa apresentar um último
exemplo do papel do "OEIRD".
Percorrer alguns casos em que a
alegação de que os norte-americanos
se destacam em relação a
outros ocidentais
nos fenômenos associados
com o individualismo
e os autoconceitos independentes.
Portanto, estas são as
perguntas clicker.
São uma série de
perguntas da pesquisa que,
pelo menos há 15 anos,
normalmente produziram respostas
muito diferentes nos cidadãos
norte-americanos educados
em comparação com os cidadãos de
outras nações industrializadas
ocidentais e não-ocidentais.
Em particular, respostas diferentes
entre os norte-americanos
em comparação com os alemães,
australianos ou japoneses.
Bom, eu só vou expor algumas perguntas.
Vamos ver como os números saem.
E vamos compará-los com os dados
encontrados nos estudos originais.
Então aqui está a 1ª questão:
"Enquanto você está
conversando e bebendo
cerveja"...
eu sei que vocês não fazem isto,
é algo para quando vocês crescerem...
"enquanto você está conversando e
bebendo cerveja com um amigo
que está oficialmente de plantão
como controlador de segurança
na empresa onde ambos
trabalham, ocorre um acidente,
ferindo um trabalhador.
Uma investigação é iniciada
pela comissão de segurança
e você é convidado a depor.
Não existem outras testemunhas.
Que direito tem o seu amigo em
esperar que você o proteja?
A) um direito definitivo.
B) algum direito.
D) nenhum direito.
A comissão está investigando...
você protege o seu amigo?
Vamos ver os números que saem.
8% de vocês acham que existe
um direito definitivo.
48% de vocês acham que
existe algum direito.
E 44% de vocês acham que
não há direito.
OK, vamos ver se podemos ver os
números anteriores...
Puxa... OK, eu estava indo
mostrar a comparação
entre os números de vocês
e os tradicionais.
Eu vou deixar estes slides para
vocês, como sempre,
e vocês podem ir e
verificar a comparação.
A ideia é que nos estudos originais
os norte-americanos se
posicionaram em 94% nesta coluna;
92% de vocês estão nestas 2 aqui.
Ao passo que, se vocês
analisarem os outros países,
as pessoas deram respostas diferentes.
A alegação não é qual é a
perspectiva legítima.
A alegação é apenas
alertá-los para o fato
de que existem diferenças radicais
na forma como as pessoas
pensam sobre o mundo.
Vamos tentar outra.
Eu não sei por que temos o
resultado aqui...
Portanto, não prestem atenção nos
números que aparecem aqui.
Você acha que "o único objetivo real
de uma empresa é fazer lucro?
Ou você acha que B) uma
empresa, além de fazer lucro
tem o objetivo de alcançar o bem-estar
das várias partes interessadas,
tais como empregados,
acionistas e outros?".
Os números de vocês sugerem
que ela também tem outros objetivos.
Mas 33% de vocês acham
que o único objetivo de uma
empresa é o lucro.
Entre os japoneses
pesquisados ??em 1993,
8% optou pela opção de 33% de vocês.
"Se você pedir um emprego numa
empresa", o seu pensamento é:
"1) que é quase certo que você
trabalhará lá pelo resto da sua vida?"
Ou a sua ideia é: "é quase
certo que o relacionamento
terá uma duração limitada"?
Vamos ver como sai este.
8% de vocês acham que vai
trabalhar lá pelo resto da vida.
92% que a duração é limitada.
Se vocês analisarem os números aqui,
vocês estão com os norte-americanos.
60% dos japoneses deram a
resposta que vocês
deram para a mesma pergunta.
Outra e outra vez – e eu vou
deixar mais 3 exemplos
para vocês analisarem – vemos
que o que você é –
se você é como os
japoneses, com 41% de vocês
diferentes dos norte-americanos,
se você é como os
norte-americanos, com 99% de
vocês
diferentes dos japoneses –,
o ambiente cultural em que
você se encontra,
tem um papel na determinação
da sua percepção.
E nós vamos começar a próxima aula
explorando uma versão particular disso
no contexto da discussão de Cass
Sunstein sobre as normas sociais.